un hommage pour saluer une figure
emblématique du sport et mi montant lors
d'un match à domicile contre Rouen
l'équipe des cougar commémorait la
mémoire Dany Couton ce dimanche 30 avril
au complexe sportif Jean maréchal cette
ancienne vice-présidente de la
Fédération Française de baseball
softball a été à la tête des cougars
entre 2008 et 2018 engagé investi elle
faisait monter l'équipe locale en
Division 1 pour la saison 2017 si
quelqu'un qui est resté à la tête du
club pendant très longtemps qui a su le
développer aussi pour être le club qu'il
est aujourd'hui donc oui en tant que
nouveau président bon ça c'est un défi
et puis aussi c'est une source
d'inspiration pour pour aller plus loin
et pour porter le club encore plus haut
en 2019 Annie couteau recevait la
médaille d'argent de la Jeunesse et des
Sports pour son investissement dans la
vie associative de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le stade des
cougar porte désormais le nom de
l'ancienne présidente décédée en octobre
2022 c'est vraiment une image pour le
club c'est quelqu'un vraiment de
formidable donc on avait besoin de faire
cet hommage ça m'est arrivé après des
déplacements où on rentre tard de Wakan
nous laisse une chambre pour dormir que
vraiment impliqué dans le club à 100%
moi ça fait 20 ans que je suis dans le
club et je la connais c'est c'est la
maman du club Annie elle était là au
terrain quasiment à tous les matchs
importants assise dans les tribunes avec
son flanc qu'elle faisait pour tous les
matchs pour honorer sa mémoire une
plaque commémorative a été dévoilée à
l'endroit où elle avait l'habitude de
s'installer dans les gradins une plaque
pour ne jamais l'oublier